I don't know this guy's forty time off
the top my head ah maybe he does here on
behalf of Verizon a man who's uh who's
certainly on the radar screens have so
many NFL teams he is Utah State
quarterback Jordan love how are used
your Jordan how are you sir you're doing
well yeah I'm good I'm doing well I
assume you're forty time is better than
your overrating correct Jordan or your
here's what we'll do is when this is
done you take a look at it and you just
let me know and you can text it and I'm
sure it's better than my four or five
for my gosh how many NFL team how many
NFL teams would you say you have spoken
to Jordan give me an estimate I mean you
know sit with the table in the combat I
say I almost talked to everybody but in
this last month on that part I talked
about ten teams so what are you what
have you been asked about the most what
do you think is the most common question
you have been asked that might give
people a window into your evaluation by
NFL scouts person I get asked a lot is
there's a lot about this life you know
the number is little different than the
2018 sees you know about seventeen their
steps so that's definitely a question
and they want to find out why that
happened
what's your answer along there you want
to find out what my mindset was
beautiful is that what's your answer to
that my answer is you know I'm trying to
do too much out down the field
I'm trying to force some balls it you
know didn't need to be thrown and trying
to make you know every play when we
didn't need it that's the reason that
yeah I mean it's it's doing I mean I
always thought that when again the XFL
was playing in a quarterback it throws
an interception and they they would have
a sideline reporter go right up to the
quarterback and say what happened
sometimes it's not your responsibility
but you pretty much as a quarterback I
have to take it all the time because
that's what everybody's looking for in
the NFL is to take responsibility for it
but that said I mean what do you think
you have to tell evaluators that you've
worked on on that front
oh I mean it's huge your song
decision-making being able to learn from
those mistakes I made and I keep being
able to watch them and understand a lot
through those pics and know how I can
change that in the future how does the
Southern California kid wind up in Utah
State Jordan uh yeah I mean that's the
only yes offer you know you got to go
where you got to go so uh yeah I ended
up going to Utah and enjoyed it out
there so that was the only school that
offered you is that what you're saying
only one yeah spawn schools you know you
still wants to in fact but ups eight
who's like that and uh yeah Utah State
was the only one to offer that put a
chip on your shoulder
oh yeah that's on my shoulder you know
time that high school being a little
recruited they make my way out there
what do you say when you hear
comparisons to Patrick my homes the ones
that I hear Jordan I mean that's a huge
comparison
my name is saying I'm worthy of that
comparison at all either he's a
fantastic player I love Washington but
uh it it is what it is you know they're
gonna compare me to whoever they want to
compare me to at the time so I I just I
don't have an opinion on that I play how
I played so yeah Jordan love here on the
Rich Eisen show the day of the 2020 NFL
Draft
so who was your guy growing up who have
you modeled your game after Jordan love
I had a lot of guys going up I say the
main one I grew up watching was Michael
day I loved watching him at the shoes
growing up and all that so of the huge
part but but me I watched everybody you
know Peyton Manning Brett Favre I'll
just try and take different pieces of
their game
have you been connected with any of
those guys have you spoken with any
other of those guys before
we're since Peyton Manning I was up
there the manna-fest Academy camp over
the summer know so Peyton and Eli were
out there I was able to know chat it up
with the energy out there work out
sounds pretty cool experience what would
you pick up from the
they did what pieces of advice did they
give you that you were able to take and
maybe put into real time for you Oh for
me I'm the I think of a line now they're
droppin just a little little knowledge
bombs on us all week you know whether we
ought to throw on the field fundamentals
we got a little class sometime when the
old man just pick their brains and ask
some questions you know about how they
watched film a big study and just trying
to better every year so I was able to
earn a lot huh
what's the strangest question you were
asked in this combine evaluation period
Jordan love me I didn't I was I was kind
of bummed I didn't get out any crazy
questions
you know I'll turn about them and
whatnot but I think you asked one but uh
the craziest when I heard somebody got
ass but gonna use up their drama play up
for the coaches and and when the coaches
said well would you go I'll punch you in
the face right now so Jordan what would
you do if I punched you in the face
right now Jordan a coach from my good
are you I mean are you so so a kid is
drawing up a play this is at the combine
that I imagine if we're talking about
face to face and an actual threat that
to carry out physical contact would be
would be feasible so that's what you
heard you heard that from the prospect
who has asked that very question yeah so
no they put some crazy question that's
you just to try and you know be in your
head rack today I'm a different
situations for me
one of the ones they threw like they
said uh five different words and state
to say the first thing comes your mind
we think of it as different team but
they just kind of want to see how you
react to it right yeah I don't know what
you glean out of that but so last one
for you on that so I imagine it's a
fellow member of the quarterback class
of the of the 2020 draft
who got asked that question trainer
would I can't think which one it was no
he
at where they were going all the
whiteboard stuff and classroom stuff and
we're just talking about questions we
got all right yeah so before I let you
go Jordan what is the one thing you've
heard about your evaluation that you
think is unfair that I could give you
the floor right now here on the Rich
Eisen show to address and say you know
what I don't think that that part of my
evaluation is accurate and I'd like to
on behalf of myself and and everybody
that's on team Jordan love correct that
before the draft tonight oh man I mean
maybe that uh I'm not know may be smart
enough plays NFL you know able to break
down defenses and uh you know Lana NSO
office just based on you know Boston
siren toss date but no huddle tempo
authors you know not the huddle CSI I
guess that'd be in for me but uh you
know just now then people understand it
I mean I'm a quarterback I play this
position and uh know I'm smart enough to
be able to understand often to break
down defenses just like the rest of them
as well and you're here on behalf of
Verizon they're helping you get
everybody together for your your
drafting tonight essentially oh yeah you
helped me a lot
as you know the draft is uh you know at
our house those two points going on so
probably just help me you know stay
connected with everybody was don't give
me a phone to give it uh no talk to my
friends to my family that uh unable to
be with me don't help me out a lot well
Jordan I we've never met that's the
first time that we have I imagine this
is going to be the first of many and I
will unsolicited ly tell you as a
veteran of being around drafts if you're
you know I hope you get drafted as high
as you want if your draft night may be
longer than you would like or expect
some of the all-time greats have waited
a very long time to hear their name
called and last years MVP of the league
somebody traded up and snagged them in
the very end of the first round so you
know if your night is a little longer
than you then you
or want it to be just take heart you are
not the first and there are many before
you that have done great things
I'll just throw that out the third I
know that I'm ready for it okay Jordan
will chat soon okay
all right thank you you bet that's
Jordan love on behalf of Horizon from
Utah State here on the Rich Eisen show
on the draft I figured I'd throw that
out there hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here